والان مشاهدينا سنتوقف مع تطورات
الميدانيه للحرب في اوكرانيا حيث تمكن
مقاتل وفاجنر من السيطره على اطراف مدينه
باخمه شمالا وجنوبا وايضا شرقا كما نتابع
هنا على هذه الخريطه ايضا استطاعت الوصول
الى مركز المدينه هنا ايضا
والمعارك الرئيسيه هي الان في بخمه هنا
مشاهدينا تتركز كل المعارك وقت طويل مر
على روسيا لم تحرز اي تقدم باي منطقه في
اوكرانيا الان هي تركز على هنا تحاول
ان تطوق هذه المنطقه من كافه الجوانب من
الشمال هناك حي ستوبكي تحاول مستميته ان
تصل اليه وايضا من الجنوب هناك حي سباشكا
ايضا المعارك تدور هناك وتتقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه ونعود ونذكر بانه من يقاتل في
هذه المنطقه بالذات في بخمت هم قوات فاجنر
هي التي تتقدم في هذه المنطقه هنا ايضا
تشتد كل المعارك في هذه المناطق بالذات
ولكن مشاهدينا هناك امر جدا مهم تحاول
قوات فاجنر ان تمنعه وهو هذا الخط هذا
الخط الذي سنتبعه سويا من هنا الى ما يسمى
بمنطقه شاذو فيار هذه المنطقه بالذات
تحاول ان قوات فاجنر تحاول ان تقطع الطريق
هذه لماذا لان الامدادات من اوكرانيا
لبخمت تصل عبر هذه او هذا الطريق اذا
اردنا ان نكملها هكذا تحاول ان تقطع هذه
الطريق حتى لا تصل الى القوات الاوكرانيه
في بخنوت وبالتالي هي تستطيع ان تطوق هذه
المنطقه وتسيطر عليها حتى ان وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تقول بانها تقريبا تبعد كيلومترين
الى حد ما عن هذه الاحياء التي تحدثنا
عنها